And she'll,
for an entirely nother universe.
I read this really cool
book by physicists.
We talked about that,
that actually there might be entry
point to different universe where the
cosmological constants are slightly
different and just like genetic mutations,
which are different in every organism,
the Dm such that instead of having a
big bang you would have actually had an
infinite number of universes constantly
kind of creating and developing through
these different black hole portals
makes actually more sense to me.
Well,
you know,
one of the things that I've always felt
like when I have like really intense
psychedelic experiences,
like would it,
the thought that,
I mean a million people have is what if
this is not actually an hallucination,
but in fact some sort of a chemical
doorway into some other state.
There's something else out there and
we're just so used to the idea that like
this chair sits on the ground and this
table sits here and a laptop sits in a
chair and this is all normal,
but we could easily be
from that DMT dimension.
That would be our normal everyday reality.
And they would come here and we would
think this is the craziest fucking
psychedelic experience ever.
Drinking red liquid from thin glasses
and talking into electrical impulses that
send them through wires.
And hundreds of thousands of people
listen and they ride out of mass
transportation on fucking elliptical
machines all over the world.
That is psychedelic,
that's psychedelic as fuck.
Well,
I mean,
that's,
if you lived in a
dimension of pure love and,
and,
you know,
and eternal consciousness,
all interconnected.
And you know,
there was,
there was no physical matter.
You would just live in the DMT realm.
This world would be a completely.